what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to a clip from the
bachelorette
i love the bachelorette i don't care
what anyone says um before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring to that ring that notification
bell um in this clip particularly
um this is the guy is a contestant on
the season of the bachelorette and he's
basically gonna freak out at the lead
i told you from the beginning i'm gonna
be open honest and yeah you know
only thing that i ask is really that you
just hear me out and
of course you know you just you give me
a chance to say all that i have to say
absolutely i mean i feel like you got a
lot to say so yeah so yeah
again i said there's been a couple red
flags that just kind of came out to me
and you know the first the first thing
that happened
um was really in our group date i
thought the day was going absolutely
amazing and
you know we fast forward into the
evening and
basically said that
um you know
like you guys are here for me
okay
and you're 100 correct we are here for
you but
like
you're here for us too
yeah like it's it's two-sided and
i've sacrificed a lot to be here i'm
missing out on time with my daughter
yeah
and
every second i'm here that's one second
i've taken away from being with my my
child honestly i get it my mom is
dying yeah
i'm sorry sorry go ahead let me continue
i'm sorry let me continue
damn he did not care
thank you thank you um
i found it really disrespectful i really
did and it's been bugging me for the
past three days like it's been really me
up and i i hate that this is the first
time i've got to talk to you about it
yeah
the second thing is
i was absolutely appalled
at
the group date that occurred
yesterday there's
naked guys you know doing airplane dodge
ball together
it's so humiliating
and degrading and i don't see how that
really translates into finding a husband
like who's willing to strip down butt
naked and play dodgeball it seems very
silly and very immature
wow
i actually i don't have any issues with
what he's saying here because
he's right like she's like almost 40
years old and you're still
you're still doing this okay
i feel like a lot of these guys they're
appeasing you
if i had been on that date i sure as
hell wouldn't have crossed that line not
in a million years would i be caught
dead doing that
all right
like if my daughter saw me doing that
and my family saw me doing that like
think of the thought they would have
think of think of think of the example
that would be setting that's why you
were not on that date
well i'm glad i wasn't yeah i'm
seriously glad i wasn't
i was
so appalled
a completely classless display
i expected a lot more from the oldest
bachelorette that's ever been
and
i i can't believe i can't believe that
that actually occurred that's not the
type of example i want set for my
daughter
you're not setting the right example
it's interesting because bachelor nation
made him seem like such a douche
um
i
i do think this is a little drama-filled
like
just tell you're not interested and
leave rather than list your reasons
like
maybe i'm just too laid back because for
me
if i'm not interested in somebody i just
stop dealing with them
you know it's
putting a gun to your head and forcing
you to be here however i think the
points he's making are valid example for
my daughter like if he doesn't want that
and a wife then
yeah that's fine like i feel like i even
have to explain now i must
like
i'm ashamed to be associated with you i
can't believe i sacrificed
so much to be here just to watch
this is distasteful in classes this way
i'm serious like so appalled going back
to our first day i feel like you
like really
overreacted
and
honestly it sounded a little crazy it
sounded like why
like that sounded crazy
what about me saying that
i want guys who are here for me
and not trying to grow out with each
other and want to get to know me i'm
looking for a husband i'm looking for
someone to hold up don't let me love me
i'm looking for something i've listened
to you no no this entire time no stop do
not stop me i'll listen to you
like seriously i asked i've listened to
you for the last 20 minutes i'm not done
yet you know what you are done let me
tell you something the way you're
talking to me right now
never in a million years claire listen
to me claire listen hey never in a
million years did i ever think i would
have to utter these words again
do not ever talk to me like that i never
thought i'd ever have to tell any man
that i would never want them being the
father of my child and i stand by that i
would never want my children having a
father like you get out of here claire
listen hey
oh
are you serious damn
damn
um all right whose side am i on
i'm honestly okay i'm on team yosef i
feel like everything he said was valid
i'm sorry bachelor nation
i'm sorry
i also think that he should have just
left instead of causing drama and
spilling about his feelings for 20
minutes just say oh i don't do that get
out but whatever
bro hey believe get ready you're not fit
to be a mother to my child that ain't
right
man
get out of here
claire is everything all right
you okay
you're completely classless claire are
you serious bro yo calm down over there
just gotta chill out dude bro i expected
way more from the oldest bachelorette
in history okay see that's where he's
losing his cool like
that that's where he's getting emotional
and
like kind of looking like a little [ __ ]
like screaming oh you're classless
you're old what like whatever just say
i'm not interested and go
like to me that that's drama that's
drama like
men say they don't want drama and then
they're gonna go about their feelings
that way
it's so easy she's got like 20
boyfriends just say i don't want to be
one of your 20 boyfriends to get out of
there what are you talking about
gone
remember you're almost 40. take your ass
old bro
are you kidding me don't do that
don't be that guy
hey she's all yours boys all right ben
bro i'm so heated right now i'm trying
not to like this exactly what i was
talking about the other day
this is exactly what i was talking about
the other day disrespectful as hell this
is just what he does
talking to a woman like that i don't
care what was done
i don't care what i've done i didn't
even do anything to that man
[Music]
oh
sick sick
[Music]
to sit there and say you're the oldest
bachelorette guess what i'm the oldest
bachelorette this 39 that's standing
here that's single because i didn't
settle for men like that
[Music]
you've been on a couple bachelorette
shows claire i'm not i'm not like
i [ __ ] with you you're pretty cool i'm a
fan but like
how many bachelorette shows you gotta go
on before maybe
maybe it's not the men i don't know um i
like claire i just think that she dates
like she's 22 and she's like 40.
um
i agree i think that the
the strip dodge ball was distasteful but
at the same time it's a show and i
how much say does she really get in that
but let me know what you think in the
comments don't forget to subscribe i'll
talk to you later